soir bonsoir
vous avez des pizzas non
oui
une pizza normale avec fromage
d'accord combien de temps 10 minutes
d'accord je porte de Saint-Cloud aux
trois obus merci
vous commandez les pizzas ailleurs et
vous les manger ici la costaud quand
même non
on fait brasserie on a pas besoin des
produits des autres
j'ai demandé
avant mais il y a pas de terrasse
des chaises découvert et de l'huile
piquante vous avez
vous faire une pizza va sur le banc en
face c'est normal
j'ai pris une entrée chez vous
voyez ce que vous devez manger
pas du tout c'est bon vous êtes pas très
serviable
c'est au bon accueil chez vous non
tu dégages
[Musique]
bonjour bonjour bonjour
du restaurant
[Musique]
c'est pas la bonne place là pourquoi
parce que vous êtes en train de chez
nous et ici il y a une entrée pour les
voitures ici et là alors bon
on va voir des relations de bonboisinage
ici c'est pas le bon endroit quoi
jambon fromage
faut pas rester là la mozzarella
on va rester là à mozzarella d'accord
s'il vous plaît
après vous pouvez pas rester là
saucisson
j'ai pas amande j'ai un choix rigole je
reviens bouge pas je reviens vous avez
pas le droit de vendre là
vos papiers les papiers du véhicule
votre extrait kbises tout au Pisto
piston
pourquoi mais tu es complètement malade
tu as pas tête
ici ça va pas
tu veux quoi
tu veux la pizza
pourquoi j'ai dit casse-toi d'ici
pourquoi dépêche-toi tu as pas le droit
de rester ici et si j'ai le droit à mon
meilleur ami mais tu veux quoi
attention arrête tes conneries
là
n'importe quoi toi tu veux complètement
fou dis-moi tu veux quoi tu as vu ta
tête non mais tu as vu ta tête là c'est
moi je vais faire la pizza ça c'est quoi
ça c'est de la merde n'importe quoi
ma pizza
c'est parti c'est chaud allez 93 rue de
Vaugirard
c'est une foule autre chose
oui
ah ouais c'est bon
dans Paris c'est sympa
bonjour c'est pour vous la pizza
s'il te plaît on a changé de nom ah bon
depuis quand donc ça fait 60 francs pour
la pizza
un peu plus quoi mais sinon comme vous
ouais
bonjour monsieur
[Musique]
c'est une société qui appartient à la
police
[Musique]
mais comme je sais que c'est un coup de
chez elle je sais ah vous saviez
passer à la télé ou pas ah ouais
j'aimerais bien passer à la télé
et vous voudriez passer à la télé bien
sûr je suis à la télé là ou pas
[Musique]
bonsoir
S
s'il vous plaît
qu'est-ce qu'il y a
[Applaudissements]
oh c'est pas un
frisbeek la nourriture allez quoi
allez sois sympa
tu veux une pizza
tu fais cuire tapis et tu veux quoi
aussi tu veux quoi dis-moi
allez vite j'ai faim
[Musique]
et en plus tu dis que mes pites elles
sont pas bonnes
et pourquoi tu étais malade je sais pas
un petit truc pas vrai peut-être tout
est frais ici ça tient avec la petite
m'énerve quoi attends
[Musique]